bonsoir à tous merci de nous rejoindre
dans le kiosque votre magazine culturel
regardons tout de suite le sommaire de
cette émission à l'occasion de la
Journée de la Femme samedi 8 mars
différents événements se préparent
manileamo célèbre les femmes aux
couleurs de l'Amérique latine et à la
verrière l'accent est mis sur les
réalisations au féminin toutes les
précisions avec notre invité dans
quelques instants du 12 au 26 mars se
tiendra le festival à tout bout de champ
à Magny-les-Hameaux Nicolas Gervais a
rencontré le groupe entre deux caisses
pour leur spectacle musical je hais les
gosses chaque semaine le 7e art est mise
à l'honneur dans notre chronique
cinéphile Bertrand Pinier responsable du
cinéma Les Yeux d'Elsa à
Saint-Cyr-l'École nous livrera son coup
de cœur
célébrer chaque année le 8 mars la
Journée internationale des droits des
femmes puis ses origines dans des
manifestations de femmes du début du 20e
siècle en Europe et en Amérique du Nord
réclamant donc le droit de vote de
meilleures conditions et les qualités
des sexes la journée internationale les
femmes est reconnue officiellement par
les Nations unies en 1977 et en 1982 en
France il s'agit d'une journée de
manifestations à travers le monde
l'occasion de revendiquer l'égalité des
droits et de faire un bilan sur la
situation des femmes dans la société
alors quelles sont ces manifestations
près de chez vous puisque c'est la
question sûrement que vous vous posez et
bien nous allons faire un tour d'horizon
et des gens va commencer à La Verrière
notamment puisque de nombreuses
animations sont organisées vendredi et
samedi nous en parlons ce soir avec
Camilla bibet
alors vous êtes chargés de l'action
culturelle
oscarabée
cette année la verrière met l'accent sur
les réalisations au féminin alors les
maisons de quartier qui sont
l'initiative en partie du l'un des
projets donc du bois de l'étang et
d'Orly parc on choisit de valoriser les
parcours de femmes et pour cela on mis
en place des rencontres avec des femmes
chefs d'entreprise vous pouvez un petit
peu nous parler de ces rencontres oui
alors on accueille trois personnes qui
vont venir témoigner qui sont deux
créatrices d'entreprises et une
troisième qui vient de créer une
association qui vise à favoriser les
rapports entre les jeunes et
l'entreprise donc il y aura trois
témoignages exactement c'est une espèce
d'échange d'expérience un échange
d'expérience un témoignage suivi de d'un
échange avec la salle où les gens vont
aussi pouvoir poser leurs questions
témoigner donc la création d'entreprises
au féminin c'est possible il y a des
succès d'ailleurs dans ces domaines
alors quels sont justement les types
d'entreprises qui seront présentes donc
sur trois personnes qui témoignent la
première vient de créer une entreprise
de Food truck c'est à dire c'est un
camion qui propose de la nourriture à
emporter là c'est de la nourriture
exotique donc pour elle c'est une
reconversion c'est une ancienne gérante
de camping qui est passionné de cuisine
et a décidé de se lancer ensuite on
accueille une personne qui a créé une
entreprise de décoration d'intérieur et
qui fait partie de l'association
créative qui est une association voilà
50e qui qui soutient les femmes dans la
création de d'entreprise et enfin la
troisième personne c'est une jeune
habitante une jeune femme de la verrière
voilà qui est ingénieur au CNRS et qui
vient de créer avec d'autres varier roi
une association qui s'appelle very
emploi et qui donc comme je le disais
vise accompagner les jeunes dans leur
découverte du monde de l'entreprise
alors durant la journée de vendredi
puisqu'il y a plusieurs temps fort s il
sera également possible d'assister à la
projection d'un court métrage réalisé
par les habitants de La Verrière alors
ce court-métrage s'intitule retour au
bercail ça traite de la place de la
femme au sein du foyer comment une est
ce projet
alors ce projet est né au sein d'un
atelier qui a lieu toutes les semaines à
la maison quartier d'Orly Park s'appelle
un atelier loisirs et partage
tout à fait quel que soit le quartier
d'ailleurs
et dans le public c'est essentiellement
des femmes mais ça n'est pas fermé aux
hommes pour autant et c'est vraiment un
lieu de convivialité c'est un temps de
d'échange pour les les habitants qu'ils
souhaitent et ils viennent partager
aussi leur savoir-faire échanger avec
d'autres
organiser des projets ensemble voilà ça
a un grand projet court-métrage est né
alors et le court-métrage en fait est né
d'une part d'une volonté chez eux
d'aborder cette thématique de la femme
au foyer qui comme je l'ai dit c'est
essentiellement des femmes donc qui leur
tenait à cœur le travail domestique de
parler un petit peu de ça et de ce que
ça représente et d'autre part d'un
projet qu'on menait ville de la verrière
qui s'est autour de la vidéo un concours
qui s'appelait La Verrière fait son
cinéma et donc ils ont décidé de
participer à ce concours et ils ont
d'ailleurs remporté le prix du public
dans la catégorie adulte très bien bah
écoutez moi je vous propose c'est qu'on
regarde justement un extrait de ce
court-métrage retour au bercail
bonsoir Comment ça va ça
tombe du bois je
suis pas pourquoi qu'est-ce qui se passe
je vois aujourd'hui
impossible de dormir les enfants qui
prient le chien qui aboie je vais je
travaille de nuit moi
tout le monde c'est moi
donc chérie je viens de me faire un
palier par les voisines c'est quoi cette
chanson elle est où maman
ça a été
dis-moi qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ici
aujourd'hui ça a un vrai bazar dans
toute la maison
faut que tu rentres et tu me demandes ce
que j'ai fait et que je te réponds que
je me suis occupé des enfants que j'ai
fait le ménage qui me réponds c'est tout
et ben aujourd'hui j'ai rien fait
alors
d'une journée d'une femme au foyer
effectivement c'est un travail aussi à
temps plein on peut le souligner
autrement fort de la journée de vendredi
alors la restitution d'un travail de
réflexion et d'écriture là encore une
fois dans les maisons de quartier les
femmes se réunissent ces travail autour
dans au sein donc de ces discussions et
des échanges qui sont menés naissent
comme ça aussi des réflexions des
projets alors qu'est-ce que ça va être
ce travail de restitution donc là c'est
né de se mettre atelier dans une
discussion autour de la place de la
femme dans la société actuelle la
représentation qu'on pouvait en avoir et
ensuite ce groupe de parole donc à
travailler avec une comédienne qui
s'appelle Marie-Paule Guillet du théâtre
du sable avec qui on travaille
régulièrement dont la compagnie a
implanté à la verrière et elles ont
essayé de mettre en forme un petit peu
toutes leurs réflexions d'abord par
l'écriture et il y aura donc vendredi
une restitution de toutes ces paroles
pour un peu mettre
en miroir ce que la société nous renvoie
des questions d'image et puis comment
elles sont perçues par ces femmes toutes
ces
injonctions la société donc elles se
sont un petit peu amusées avec ça et
elles vont faire la lecture des textes
qu'elles ont écrit donc
mise en exergue un peu de stéréotypes
quand même oui c'est un jeu sur les
stéréotypes ouais bon alors donc ça
c'est vendredi vendredi de 11h30 à 16h
au scarabée et le samedi bah c'est aussi
au scarabée qu'il va falloir se rendre
et à partir de 20h30 pour un concert
cette fois-ci ce sont les
chatouillesuses et lui
donc à la base c'est un trio
qui a été fondé vers 2010 aux alentours
2010 par trois personnes donc deux
femmes et un homme le fameux lui
donc c'est génie et Françoise qui sont
chants et au piano et puis Jean-Michel
qui est à la guitare qui les accompagne
et en fait ce sont des histoires
du quotidien
aborder d'un point de vue féminin
puisque ce sont elles qui écrivent les
chansons et c'est son temps l'humour et
c'est sur le ton humour on a voulu une
soirée un peu légère c'est assez Spiegle
c'est vraiment un regard tendre mais des
fois un peu malicieux sur les travers de
la gente féminine et masculine surtout
et sur les relations homme-femmes voilà
on va regarder là aussi enfin on va
écouter parce que on n'a pas de de scène
proprement dit mais on va écouter un
extrait de leur morceau
toujours en retard ils arrivaient à
croire qu'ils avaient pas lire l'heure
une fois sur deux ils oubliaient c'était
de vrais marathiners ils l'ont été tout
au lendemain et parfois ça prenait des
mois pour qu'un meublique et enfin soit
installé comme il se doit souvent il
pratiquait est-ce qu'il j'aurais aimé
appeler l'initiative il s'appelait à
bien Bertrand Sébastien Pascal
arriver à la chie de Ludovic il
s'appelait Fabien Bertrand Sébastien
Pascal Louis je les ai cherché je les ai
trouvés je suis pas resté soyons logique
voilà donc des chansons où on se
retrouve oui on retrouve chacun un peu
ce qu'on a vécu à un moment ou un autre
alors vous Camilla quel regard justement
vous portez sur la place de la femme
alors plus précisément dans la culture
un style grand une grande question je
crois que dans comme dans d'autres
domaines
il y a effectivement peut-être une
prépondérance de l'agence masculine même
si les femmes sont très nombreuses à
travailler dans les minutes culturelles
ou qui a des femmes artistes mais je
pense souvent de direction moins
valorisées voilà moins dans les
décisions sur les postes de direction
c'est vrai quand vous lisiez on trouve
beaucoup de de comédiennes d'interprète
effectivement maintenant sur des postes
de metteurs en scène mais deux en scène
puisque on peut aussi féminiser les mots
ou d'auteurs effectivement parfois il y
a PAF toujours d'égalité alors je
voulais juste préciser que sur le
territoire le prisme Élancourt et la
ferme de belléba à Guyancourt eux se
donnent comment dire une attention
particulière à donner une certaine
égalité dans leur programmation aussi
bien aux hommes qu'aux femmes
qu'en est-il du schaerbee alors c'est
vrai que sur le scarabée on
procède un peu différemment sur notre
sur notre programmation
on fonctionne beaucoup au coup de coeur
et sur l'instant donc elle est très liée
à l'actualité musicale qui sort un album
qui est en tournée aussi parce qu'on
n'est pas tout à fait sur les mêmes
temporalités que dans le théâtre ou dans
la danse et selon les saisons c'est
assez variable donc on a accueilli une
grande artiste féminine qu'on est ravis
d'avoir eu sur scène
mais on comptabilise pas précisément
combien de femmes combien d'hommes
seront présents sur la scène du scarabée
bon très bien alors on rappelle que au
prisme par exemple la direction est
menée par par une femme Sabine coussin
et on en souhaite plein d'autres dans
d'autres lieux culturelles du territoire
merci Camilla donc rendez-vous
oscarabée vendredi de 11h30 à 16h et
puis samedi à partir de 20h30 pour le
concert des chatouillesuses et lui alors
nous on va partir maintenant du côté de
Magny-les-Hameaux pour une autre
illustration de la journée de la femme
et d'événements donc consacré à la femme
et même aux femmes du monde des images
dès le dimanche
Amani les hameaux ce n'est pas une
journée mais une semaine durant laquelle
la femme les femmes du monde sont
célébrées à l'occasion de la Journée
internationale des droits des femmes le
samedi 8 mars la Ville et les
associations partenaires organisent une
semaine d'animation cette année sur la
thématique de l'Amérique du Sud au
programme par exemple visite à
l'estaminet de deux expositions
consacrées aux femmes d'Amérique latine
ateliers cuisine ou tacos et autres
empanada se réveille les papilles ou
encore cours de gym en rythme sur des
musiques oui caliente
au travers de ces invitations au voyage
l'objectif est de créer des moments de
partage et d'échanges pour les femmes on
ne fait pas des ateliers pour faire des
ateliers il faut qu'il soit un sens et
le sens c'est le lien entre elles avec
les autres
pas seulement entre femmes d'ailleurs
parce que
la semaine de la femme soit concerne pas
que les femmes tout le monde est invité
etc et c'est vrai que ça ça permet
vraiment de elles font connaissance de
plus en plus entre elles elles échangent
au niveau de leurs enfants par rapport à
leurs enfants par rapport à l'éducation
c'est le sens c'est ça c'est le lien
social quel type d'entre elles voilà et
avec le quartier avec la ville et puis
c'est aussi une façon de comment dire de
faire comprendre aux femmes de
comprendre nous-mêmes aussi
de quoi on est capable en fait parce que
on sait faire des tas de choses on peut
faire des tas de choses on le sait tout
le monde ne le sait pas mais bon voilà
c'est prendre confiance nous le plus en
plus je crois qu'on y arrivera que comme
ça
gagner en confiance en soi se sentir à
l'aise avec son corps et oser être belle
ce sont là les maîtres mots donnés au
cours de l'atelier de conseil en images
dispensé également cette semaine ces
données des astuces et des conseils
faciles à réaliser au quotidien
et pour tout public voilà jeune moins
jeune parce qu'en fait le loup qui
concerne tout le monde j'aime beaucoup
cette ce lien qui se tisse avec les
dames ce côté aussi où on laisse tous
les soucis on parle un peu chiffon on
parle beauté qu'on soit maman jeune à la
recherche d'emploi c'est ce côté entre
femmes super comment dirais-je elle se
laisse un peu est-ce qu'on fuit on
rigole
l'atelier aux allures de réunion entre
amis apportent les clés pour apprendre
notamment à se maquiller associer les
couleurs qui mettent en valeur et
s'habiller en fonction de sa morphologie
parce que si vous regardez bien par
rapport à tout à l'heure vous devez
trouver une différence dans les yeux ça
peut aider voilà reprendre confiance en
soi
suite à un divorce je suis recherche
d'emploi enfin diverses choses dans ce
sens on se sent soutenu et des c'est
fait dans la journée dans l'abonnement
et avec beaucoup de d'empathie
on fait des zigzags la journée du samedi
8 mars annonce elle aussi sous le signe
de la convivialité de 10 heures à 16h
place au plaisir sportif entre autres
cours d'aérobox Zumba rally pédestre et
des 20h30 la soirée se clôture par le
concert salsa de Yemaya 12 musiciennes
venus des quatre coins du monde
retrouvons sans plus attendre Nicolas
Gervais pour sa chronique dans le
kiosque
du 12 au 26 mars se tiendra le festival
à tout bout de champ à Magny-les-Hameaux
Nicolas Gervais a rencontré le groupe
entre deux caisses pour leur spectacle
musical je hais les gosses
il reprenne brillamment les chansons
d'Alain Leprest pour un spectacle jeune
public et tout public intitulé Je hais
les gosses qui sera présentée le 20 mars
à l'estaminet à Magny-les-Hameaux dans
le cadre du festival à tout bout de
champ et en partenariat avec la maison
de la poésie de Saint-Quentin en
Yvelines voici entre deux caisses dans
le kiosque et tu vas voir ça va te
plaire
le cafetière Kafa la cafetière est
partie trotter sur les trottoirs de
Paris on existe depuis
1997 notre première date sur scène était
le 10 janvier 1997 donc on a commencé à
travailler en 1986 ça fait 18 ans qu'on
travaille ensemble
sur Entrée de caisse c'est un coiffeur
des instruments la contrebasse
l'accordéon les clarinettes et là sur ce
spectacle d'ulcimera marteau qui a été
rajouté
on est tous chanteurs
on est presque tous instrumentiste sauf
Jean-Michel qui est chanteur donc
chanteur sec
et aussi de chanter à plusieurs voix de
faire du cœur aussi au lendemain
on connaissait très bien pour avoir fait
une création en 2005 au Théâtre
d'Ivry-sur-Seine avec les lacu Kerman la
directrice on s'est elle quand Alain est
parti en 2011
il était livré elle a voulu marquer le
coup et puis elle a dit tiens j'aimerais
bien quand même porter ses chansons aux
enfants mais pas le répertoire en France
c'est-à-dire son opéra qu'il avait créé
écrit Fantin mais c'est vraiment ses
chansons les porter aux enfants à partir
de 8 ans quoi CE2 CM1 CM2 et elle a dit
ben voilà je pense à vous
pas sentir les fût la
piscine fleur mords les choux devant les
embrassent et on vive la pince les
cuisses c'est mon truc c'est bon ça sert
ce élégance
je
hais les gosses
on a réussi à sortir quelque chose où on
s'est dit
ça doit être écoutable c'est audible
pour ces 8 ans et tout ça c'est pas
facile même c'est pas facile mais ça
fonctionne on l'a fait on a on a fait
des séances que pour les enfants de des
scolaires et ça fonctionne très bien
d'accord une petite histoire pour pour
amener les chansons les unes aux autres
et c'est vrai c'est un petit peu comme
un con quoi
dame la comtesse SS ne m'en garder des
aucun grief
FDF j'ai trop de parades SS pour mieux
tard
dans votre fief
SCF chacun sa messe SS et ses idées
chacun sa nef
SDF c'est la mise en espace avec oui un
tout petit jeu qui a été mis par
Juliette quand même donc il faut quand
même la citer parce qu'elle a fait un
gros travail avec nous aussi bien sur
l'aspect sénique que sur l'aspect
musical parce que cela se fait musical
on est arrivé on a dit voilà on lui a
présenté des choses et puis on a eu son
retour de musicienne qui nous a dit les
garçons là là ça sonne c'est dommage
comment vous avez fait proposer moi
autre chose donc on a on a retravaillé
pour le lendemain des choses c'était
super de travailler avec elle
comment ça va Jérôme
c'est le nom alors que les enfants
ces choses indiens étrangement
c'est un voyage dans le temps où se
situe dans les années à 3000 ou je sais
pas et puis on dit aux gens voilà ce qui
se passait autour de l'an 2000 alors
bien sûr ils sont très au courant ils y
sont alors c'est assez c'est assez drôle
de c'est assez on va pas tout dire il
faut qu'il vienne nous voir
grâce à la à l'association ou au lieu le
théâtre l'estaminet et aussi à la Maison
de la poésie de Saint-Quentin on a on a
pu faire un projet avec les enfants un
petit peu en avancé ils apprennent des
chansons d'Alain convainc le jour du
spectacle à Manille faire ensemble après
le spectacle pas avant mais après
aussitôt qu'on a fini on dit aux enfants
de venir et on fait les deux trois
chansons qu'on a travaillé et on les
chante ensemble mon premier boulot a été
avant de faire que de la scène a été
d'enseigner en milieu scolaire donc j'ai
fait ça pendant 10 ans donc d'amener la
chanson aux enfants moi je trouve ça je
trouve ça super et on voit bien que ça
fonctionne là le travail avec
l'institutrice de de Guyancourt et
remarquable
et voici pour entre deux caisses et
maintenant on retrouve Aurélia sur le
plateau du kiosque
chaque semaine le 7e art est mise à
l'honneur dans notre chronique cinéphile
et c'est au tour de Bertrand Pinier
responsable du cinéma Les Yeux d'Elsa à
Saint-Cyr-l'École de nous livrer son
coup de cœur
alors notre coup de coeur au cinéma Les
Yeux d'Elsa à Saint-Cyr-l'École cette
semaine à partir du mercredi 5 mars donc
c'est le film American bluff American
bluff c'est à mon sens le grand oublié
des de la cérémonie des Oscars vous
allez trouver
non pas un ou deux mais 5 acteurs
absolument formidables et qui sont tous
complètement à contre emploi dans des
dans des manières d'être qu'on n'a pas
du tout l'habitude de voir chez eux ils
sont évidemment complètement grimés ils
portent des perruques énormes ils ont
des costumes complètement extravagants
qui nous font nous dire que les années
70 devaient être particulières du point
de vue vestimentaire et qui nous raconte
une histoire d'escroquerie complètement
abracadabrant à laquelle on comprend pas
forcément grand chose mais c'est pas le
sujet du film le sujet du film c'est
justement l'histoire de la permanente
escroquerie des rapports humains et donc
de cette de ce bluff gigantesque dans
lequel les hommes et les femmes entre
eux se mène par le bout du nez voilà
avec en toile de fond tout de même une
vraie belle et profonde histoire d'amour
entre Christian Bell et Amy Adams je
vous invite à venir voir ce film c'est
une vraie et belle découverte il faut
qu'on arrive à entuber tous ces gars là
on ne doit penser qu'à ça à partir de
maintenant réussir à entuber tous ces
gars
ça sera le meilleur coup qu'on n'est
jamais fait
je vous propose à présent quelques idées
de sortie ces prochains jours alors tout
d'abord une soirée salsa solidaire une
initiation à la danse est prévue à 20h30
à 21h un cours de salsa et à partir de
22h30 différentes démonstrations donc ce
sera vendredi à l'espace de Coville de
Voisins-le-Bretonneux une partie des
recettes sera reversée à une association
caritative samedi 8 mars à 11h30 vous
pourrez rencontrer Pierre Lemaître
l'auteur du prix Goncourt 2013 au revoir
là-haut autour d'un verre à la librairie
du pavé du canal à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux et pour les
jeunes la journée internationale des
droits des femmes peut amener à la
réflexion c'est quoi être un gars ou une
fille enfin en tout cas c'est la
question qui est posée aux enfants de 10
à 13 ans au cours de l'atelier de philo
d'Anne-Sophie à l'estaminet à
Magny-les-Hameaux samedi à 17h voilà
notre émission est à présent terminée
merci de nous avoir suivis sur TV fixes
je vous retrouve donc la semaine
prochaine en direct à 18h30 à mercredi